you know what's absolutely insane right
now the fact that the us government is
putting together a ministry of truth
basically the us government gets to
decide what is misinformation and what
is not they basically get to decide
reality and nobody is outraged about
this this is concerning for two main
reasons number one it's a political body
that's putting it together and politics
always has agendas number two what is
misinformation is starting to change on
a regular basis so about a year ago if
you said that the injections weren't 100
effective and could cause serious side
effects that would be classed as
misinformation and you would be
cancelled and taken down one year later
we obviously know that actually this is
correct but what that's doing is it's
cancelling truth and it's canceling
reality so the us government literally
has a hold on deciding what is reality
and what isn't and let's not forget this
is the same benevolent government that
lied to you over the last two years that
printed endless amounts of money
devaluing the very money sitting in your
pocket that's causing eight and a half
percent inflation if you believe that
number pushing the middle and the
working class down deeper into poverty
and it's no surprise that this comes
after elon musk making twitter the
platform of free speech so naturally
that's going to hinder the government's
propaganda machine so guys please spread
this message share it with everyone let
everybody know that it's absolutely
absurd that the us government is
creating an orwellian style ministry of
truth